gelée
Oh oh oh
[musique]
vaudou
Mugla
moi
Oh oh oh
[musique]
Murray
moi
oufufu
Après tout, il existe des coronavirus de divers parcs d'attractions et sociétés d'événements, donc cet été
Tout comme l'annulation
J'ai reçu de plus en plus d'appels et j'ai été choqué qu'il y en ait plus que ce à quoi je m'attendais.
ce
Peut-être est-il juste de dire que je le supporterai jusqu'à ce que le roulis printanier disparaisse
peut être
Je pense qu'il y a diverses opinions sur les objections, mais nous ferons tout ce que nous pourrons
Une maison hantée même si elle prend une autre forme
Je veux continuer Je veux rendre heureux les gens que j'aime Je veux qu'ils aient peur
Je veux faire de mon mieux parce que j'ai le sentiment fort que
[musique]
moi
Avec le client dans la voiture
Si vous créez un système où les fantômes vous menacent parce que vous ne touchez pas à l'envers, c'est ce que c'est
Rendre les clients heureux en toute sérénité même dans des situations difficiles
Tout a commencé quand j'ai pensé que je pouvais faire une maison hantée.
Non
Si je suis surpris, je peux m'enfuir, n'est-ce pas ?
Mais ce trajet s'appelle une maison hantée, donc je suis coincé dans la voiture tout le temps, alors je m'enfuis
Il y a un moment où la peur de ne pas pouvoir le faire est plus forte que la maison hantée de cet été.
Je n'entends pas le son de l'application si c'est une voiture Kane, donc c'est
Même si vous parlez si fort, cela ne sera pas transmis à l'intérieur, donc le son de la voix
J'ai déjà incorporé la voix d'un fantôme ou la voix d'un acteur dans le son qui jouait dans la voiture.
Le fait que nous agissions ensemble est très difficile cette fois à l'atelier d'ingéniosité.
C'est un endroit appelé un magasin qui est de l'autre côté de la vitrine.
La distance avec le client n'est pas étroite et la distance sociale est correctement protégée
Ainsi, la distance entre vous et le client devient très proche.
Il y a beaucoup de choses qui le rendent intéressant quand on voit de près les réactions incroyables.
dire la même chose
[musique]
Oh
Hummm
oufufu
Oh oh oh
[musique]
Oui